what I want to do now is figure out
what's the minimum speed that the car
has to be at the top of this loop loop
in order to stay on the track in order
to stay in the circular motion in order
to not fall down like this and I think
we can all appreciate that that is the
most difficult part of the loop-de-loop
at least in the bottom half right over
here the track itself is actually what's
providing the the the centripetal force
to keep it going in a circle but when
you get to the top you now have to you
now have gravity that is pulling down on
the car almost completely and the car
will have to maintain some minimum speed
in order to stay in a circular in order
to stay in this circular path so let's
figure out what that minimum speed is
and to help figure that out we have to
figure out what the radius of this loop
the loop actually is it actually does
not look like a perfect circle based on
this little screenshot that I got here
it looks a little bit elliptical but it
looks like the curve the the radius of
curvature right over here is actually
smaller than the radius of the curvature
of the entire loop-de-loop that this if
you made this into a circle it would
actually be maybe even a slightly
smaller circle but let's just assume for
the sake of our arguments right over
here for the sake of our argument right
over here that this thing is a perfect
circle and if it was a perfect circle
let's think about what that minimum
velocity would have to be up here at the
top of the loop the loop so we know that
the magnitude of your centripetal
acceleration is going to be equal to
your speed squared divided by the radius
of your of the circle that you are going
around now at this point right over here
at the top which is going to be the
hardest point the magnitude of our
acceleration this is going to be 9.81
m/s^2
and the radius we can estimate I copied
and pasted the car and it looks like I
can get it to stack on itself four times
to get the radius of this circle right
over here and I looked it up on the web
in a car about this size is going to be
about 1.5 meters high from the bottom of
the tires
the top of the car and so it looks like
just eyeballing it based on these
copying and pasting of the cars that the
radius of this loop the loop right over
here is six meters so this right over
here is six meters so you multiply both
sides by six meters actually we could
keep it just in the variables so let me
just rewrite it just to manipulate it so
we can solve for V we have V squared
over R is equal to a and then you
multiply both sides by r you get V
squared is equal to a times R and then
you take the principal square root of
both sides you get V is equal to the
principal square root of a times R and
then if we plug in these numbers this
velocity that we have to have in order
to stay in the circle is going to be the
square root of nine point eight one
meters per second squared meters per
second squared times six meters times
six meters and you can verify that these
units workout meters times meters is
meter squared per second squared you
take the square root of that you're
going to get meters per second let's get
our calculator out to actually calculate
this so we are going to get the
principal square root of nine point
eight one times six meters it gives us
now here's our drum roll seven point six
seven I'll just round to three
significant digits seven point six seven
meters per second squared and
significant digits the whole
conversation because this is just a very
very rough approximation I'm not able to
measure this that accurately at all but
I get a roughly seven point I'll just
round seven point seven meters per
second so this is approximately seven
point seven meters per second and just
to give a sense of how that translates
into units that we're used to when we're
driving cars we can convert 7.7 m/s
seven point seven meters per second if
we want to say how many meters we go in
an hour
well there's 3,600 3,600 seconds in an
hour and if you want to convert that
into kilometers this will be in meters
you divide by a thousand one kilometer
is equal to 1000 is equal to 1000 meters
and you see here the unit's cancel out
you have meters meters seconds seconds
you're left with kilometers per hour
so let's actually calculate this and so
we get our previous answer we want to
multiply it times 3600 to figure out how
many meters in an hour and then you
divide by a thousand to convert it to
kilometers per hour so you divide by a
thousand and we get 27.6 km/h so this is
equal to twenty seven point six
kilometers per hour which is
surprisingly slow I would have thought
that it would have to be much much much
faster but it turns out it does not have
to be much much faster only twenty seven
point six kilometers per hour
now the important thing to keep in mind
is this is just fast enough at this
point to maintain the circular motion
but if this were a perfect circle right
over here and you were going in exactly
27.6 km/h you would not have much
traction with the road and if you don't
have much traction with the road the car
might slip and might not be able to
actually maintain its speed so you
definitely want to be a good bit you
might you want your speed to be a good
bit larger than this in order to keep a
nice margin of safety in order to
especially have traction with the actual
loop-de-loop and to be able to maintain
your speed now what I want to do in the
next video is actually time the car to
figure out how long does it take it to
do this loop-de-loop and we're going to
assume that it's a circle and we're
going to figure it out and we're going
to figure out how fast it's actual
average velocity was over the course of
this loop the loop